we're live slash adam's tires
that's what i would do go with slashes
tires
if you can find his car out there slash
you mean his bike i'm doing this for the
benefit of us adam relax buddy we're
live that we don't want people to know
the true story about slashing your tires
uh-oh i hear myself am i uh one of the
audios is up anyways hey we are live
episode 93 a lot's going on we got phil
heath in the house seven times strolling
piano
we got gerard in the house and we got
sauce in the house sauce you were just
at an event yesterday or two days tell
us about it what was that all about it's
called the oslo freedom forum got
invited by your good friend gary
kasparov
the the what the goat of chess the
grandma the goat the goat
um yeah he he was there i said hi to him
i actually had the chance to interview
him a quick little interview as he was
the chairman yeah he gave you a shout
out i saw our good friend john me park
there
uh weaker activists nigerian activists
uh an iraqi comedian who is hilarious
um basically these are people who fight
for freedom the biggest takeaway is
and i might even curse here like if
you're in america
just be thankful and shut the [ __ ] up
and be happy that you're here i know i
know pitbull said that yeah and you know
it really crystallized
what is going on all around the world
how bad things are for a lot of people
authoritarian regimes
people went ham on china ham like there
was a we can go i mean we might cover
some of the china stuff today
um but it was it was
people from all around the world
advocating for human rights
exposing authoritarian regimes and just
all about freedom this must have been
very traumatizing for you i hope you're
okay i don't know what that means but it
was it was good it was a great event we
interviewed a lot of awesome people
uh valuetainment got a lot of love from
a lot of the fellow
journalists um and um attendees and uh i
think we'll we'll have a great episode
from it i love it i look forward to and
by the way maybe folks may because mr
olympia this week is this weekend right
yes sir mr olympia's this weekend and
there may be a sighting maybe we have to
talk about it afterwards there may be a
south side because uh uh uh uh adam may
go you know you may do something there
but at the same time uh we were talking
about whether you're into fitness girls
like you know competitors things like
that you were a little bit hesitant was
that like uncomfortable for you the
models maybe not fitness strong
extremely cut-offs
there's
bikini girls too i'm all here so they
got bikini olympia competitors okay
you're not turning here's the challenge
though
i got it you know i got a whole bag full
of posing chunks too so if you really
have the urge all right little little
close down pose down yeah man i mean
just you know throw some tan on you know
definitely got to shave you know yeah
you know grooming but i don't know if
you've seen
that his last five posts he's had no
shirt on
uh he's dropped 50 pounds he's he's out
there it's amazing he's out there and
did you say no shirt on not i haven't
seen not just shirt but first time i've
seen gerard with a shirt on in about two
weeks the only thing is we don't know if
he's actually
that's the only thing because we can see
his feet yeah that was the only thing
but
one tiny little tiny tiny black strip
over his uh john you really didn't until
that tiny time you really did that
though
he hasn't lost 50 pounds
i'm gonna tell him gerard is making
major progress props to you buddy you
look great your energy is different and
it's great to see you thanks guys in the
shape that you're in so mr olympia do
you have any predictions you kind of
have an idea yeah you know right now uh
you have the reigning champion uh big
grammy yeah um
more than likely he is the favorite he
is the guy that's going to repeat
who's standing in his way is uh hadi
chopin from iran yeah he's trained by my
trainer hani rambod and i've been able
to see some pics
uh he's looking really dangerous right
now what's the chances of hottie beating
rami i think it's
all about who peaks not just on friday
but who slams the door on saturday
i definitely feel that the way the
judging criteria is
is not swayed to just rammy because ramy
has only peaked truly maybe a couple
times in his career and i know his
trainer chad nichols who trained ronnie
coleman who worked with him for all
those olympia wins understands
how imperative it is to not just do
friday but also saturday the timing of
the chat
the timing is everything i mean that's
something that i you know made sure of
but with hottie he does not
miss
so i think with ramy being the size that
he is he can miss maybe one of those
days so and then you have brandon curry
i mean you know he's a former mr olympia
he's a one-time so that's really your
top three and i'm really excited to see
those three guys get up there and then
you have the guys like william bonak you
have nick walker nick walker who just
won the arnold classic yeah a lot of
hype going in yeah it's going to could
be nick win could does nick stand a
chance to be first place or no okay no
top three
maybe if some guys miss how big of a
deal is it to win the arnold classic
going into mr oh like is it a really
really big deal or not i think this year
it helps him tremendously because of the
fact that the arnold was two weeks prior
to the olympia normally the arnold
classic is in march
so you have like that six months yeah is
it healthy filled to having to be that
close to each other like mr olympia and
arnold i mean health-wise that's gotta
be it's definitely difficult to to peak
for a two-day show doing a one-day show
i mean
that's easy yeah but when you're doing a
one-day show and then two weeks after
that you've got to do a two-day show
you know
the peaking what do you mean what do you
mean by peaking phil and like how long
is that window so you have to consider
like let's just say
you have a usain bolt he's getting ready
for the olympics but he's doing like an
event like an invitational like let's
say a month prior
let's just say he wants a world record
time in the world you know before the
olympics is that smart
probably not because you really want to
win
the olympic final with the world record
time so it's all about the timing so you
kind of have to pace yourself but the
problem is the body is not static is
very very dynamic so whatever worked for
nick
or anyone for these previous shows
you have to now realize that diet that
training
you might want to just rip that up and
just look at what's going on with your
body right now
and that's something that a lot of
people
miss
so a lot of people that even watch this
they've dieted but because of the fact
that their body does change
and they didn't change with it yeah they
they miss so that's why all these fat
diets keep going so but bodybuilders
have that problem too
so so you got for you like let's just
say by the way does vegas have odds on
these things or no there's vegas they
should they don't but they don't okay
why not because it's well
yeah it's kind of sticky with the
that's very uh
oh
when they're like pat said there's a
reason why there's no vegas odds in this
i mean people could be compromised in
some way shape or form i mean we don't
need to go down there that could be a
whole nother you think that's a good
thing that there's not a vegas odds yeah
i think so one million percent yeah the
integrity of it
at least in boxing you know
boxing is one of the dirtiest when it
comes down to manipulating and buying
people out i've had people on that have
told me you have no idea what kind of
people have bought and how much how easy
it is to buy that right in bodybuilding
it's very uh uh what do you call it it's
you know technical yet you can kind of
say well objective yeah subjective
that's the word i'm looking forward to
be objective yet subjective so like if
you look at all the mr olympia champions
they're all different in their own way
so right now you have ramy like that's a
guy that is
ramming i would like to see there's no
one that looks like rammy right i love a
big ramekin so there's no one that looks
like him he's like he's like the
modern-day ronnie right there it's not a
run the guy's going to be over 300
pounds ripped oh damn no no one's gonna
look like this yeah kai pull up some
images of these guys who are we looking
okay no no do the one with ronnie and uh
romney right next to each other even
though it's not real click on that no no
this is my instagram post if you could
pull up
look at that right there to two of them
insane what rami looks like
so that's romney on the right phil was
as big as these guys when he was winning
well it was i was definitely not the
same weight as rammy you know even he's
on the right yes and ronnie's on the
left yeah so like when my last olympia
win in 2017 i actually did
um beat ramy and uh you beat the guy in
the right yeah damn phil why beat these
guys were over 10 plus years
back to back to back i know who phil is
but uh but ramy is definitely one of
those guys that even when i was winning
yeah i would see him and say
if this guy gets in real good shape yeah
he's gonna be a problem for everybody so
first place romney second place
you know what's funny i i actually
my oddball is william bonak
because he didn't do the arnold
and i think it gave him maybe more time
to peak for the olympia could it be top
three i think so i mean like it's just
well here's my money my money
would be
a 1a1b with hottie and ramy because
they're so different yet dude if hottie
wins oh man it's gonna be crazy if he
wins this is rammy right here go on
hottie chopin yeah who's hi chopin wins
the olympia i may have to drive up to
orlando congratulations guy gets the
spelling right it's zero h-h-a-d-i yeah
there you go there you go but click on
that everybody's looking for that there
you go they want that this is what
people want they want is he indian the
guy the righteous person so they want
they want egypt egypt versus iran
basically is that oh he's egyptian he's
around but rami is
but when you look at look at the legs
but look at even but here's the thing
yeah
look at look at ramy but then look at
hottie
deeper cuts
you know much deeper separation
so these are things that like this is
this is the judging this has to be seen
live because to me that there's it's
indecipherable so so it's so here's what
i would suggest
what if phil on saturday night okay
what if you go live and you watch mr
olympia live and you give feedback on it
and anybody that wants to tune in they
can tune in and see you giving feedback
on the contest [ __ ] it i say we do it
you're not gonna go no i'm not going
you're not going
i'm not going so okay why not why not
why why wouldn't the fans want to see me
do commentary on on the guys you'd
rather you'd rather at the end of the
day i mean i'm gonna give these guys
justice okay you know i definitely feel
that um
they would want to know my opinion
yeah but more importantly
i've competed against these guys for
over 10 years
i understand their strengths their
weaknesses
but um
i have no axe to grind either which is
great
and i'm gonna be unbiased well the best
part is and unfortunately in our sport
it's one of those things where you
happen to
look at something
and then you just [ __ ] on it
because you're looking at their
weaknesses yeah and i think you don't
sell the sport without yeah you're going
to talk about the weaknesses but you're
going to highlight their strengths
because at the end of the day this is
what these guys train for it's the
person who has the most strength and the
least amount of weaknesses wins i have a
question for you phil and this may be
the week the
entire audience can kind of get some
perspective here
everyone out there gets judged on their
performance their work performance how
they're looking you know you show up to
the office oh your rough night but uh
it's constantly you're on social media
people are hating people are commenting
whatever
you are putting yourself out there for
the world to see literally every inch of
your body minus right
my question is regarding self-confidence
and body image
do you ever like get on stage and be
like i don't know i don't feel so good
today or
the the judgment the cause of judgment
that like every
like instagram models are
you know they they clean up every little
image every little curve are you
thinking about it are you constantly
thinking
that you know before i get on there i
gotta understand what the mentality of
it all at the end of the day break that
down you know what to get on for his
birthday already hundred percent one of
those absolutely i got him yeah okay
okay
no i'm thinking
magenta okay i could do it i could pull
that off would you take that picture and
post it on instagram
how much money i could be bought i could
give it
but at the end of the day yes
bodybuilders have
definitely i mean i'm raising my hand
right now
the insecurity absolutely the anxiety
that these guys and these girls are
going through this week they've trained
an entire year
to get ready to go up on stage and be
adjudicated by
judges who
may or may not like their physique
and then they're going to be adjudicated
by millions of people on social media
to reduce the noise is what is key for
each male and female that is competing
this week reducing the noise staying
within yourself
because there's this thing that my
trainer and i call the f up fairy and
the f up ferry is going to creep into
your mind it's kind of like what
fighters go through
you know they kind of go dark they get
weird and sometimes that's how they get
knocked the hell out in the first round
because they really get in their head
about what's going on
it's important
that each and these each of these people
know who the hell they are
and realize that it's you versus you
you cannot control it's not like boxing
where you can go knock the person out
you can't play offense defense you have
to make sure that you peak the best way
you can and that's it and you just have
to
let it let the chips fall but the
insecurity absolutely the anxiety
absolutely i mean i've had it it'll keep
you up at night it'll piss you off i
mean you'll go through various emotions
but that's why the most emotionally
intelligent
know how to run this
race won this seven times in a row let
it go i think there's certain things in
life you shouldn't aspire to do mr
obviously let me live my life i say you
skipping let me live a life i say you
skip go be go be the wide receiver for
like a local senior uh you know senior
nfl team whatever and you know do that
why shortly we will come root for you i
guaran i'll be your biggest fan i'll be
your biggest fan anyways we've got a lot
of topics to get into
bodybuilding world if you want to see
phil do a live this saturday on mr
olympia commentary uh let us know uh
give us a thumbs up if that is what you
want to hear and by the way see
follow the content follow field to make
sure if that does end up happening you
know where to find it as well it's most
likely going to end up being on
valuetainment so with that being said i
just asked the question what are some
topics you want us to cover
somebody said the pandora papers we'll
cover that
china
facebook we'll cover that
we've got a few other things that happen
andrew yang just came out and says he
doesn't want to be a democrat anymore
he's joining the independent party he's
like i'm leaving the democratic party to
be an independent this is a guy who
created a ton of momentum for himself i
wonder what's going to happen with his
job at cnn and all the stuff that he's
doing are they going to keep him are
they going to fire him is he still going
to commentate we'll see he's a guy that
definitely marketed himself very well in
the last election i think this is a guy
that's not going to be going away
there's a market for him and good for
him to announce that he's an independent
now so
we have a few things that happened the
pandora papers we got facebook that was
down yesterday for i don't know how many
hours that was six seven eight hours
china tightens a political control over
internet giants
inflation another new inflation
key inflation gauge watched by federal
reserve hits a 30-year high
what else restaurants are down playboy
releases october cover
featuring a man for the first time not
playgirl but playboy featuring a man for
the first time microsoft ceo warns
people will vote with their feed when it
comes to return to work policy biggest
crash in world history personal finance
expert robert kiyosaki predicts economic
crisis
in october is uh coming kai i don't know
if you guys got to hold them see if you
can get a hold of more now let mario
know if we can get a hold of them if not
um see if we can get him on the second
half of this schumer escalates pressure
on debt limit and something interesting
happened in the bathroom yesterday when
kristen cinema was going to the bathroom
she was chased down maybe we'll comment
on that seven out of uh 10 states and
the worst financial condition are run by
democrats i don't know why trump knows
uh says he knows what would happen if he
faces desantis in 2024 presidential
primary which is what we discussed in
the last podcast with uh danielle and
who else was on
and then a few other things that we got
here so let's see which story do we go
into which story do we go into let's go
into the new york restauranters first uh
page three business first so new york
restaurant there's business down 40 to
60 percent
due to
vaccine
mandates this is a zero hit story um new
york city restaurants are complaining
that their business has been slashed
severely by the kova 19 vaccine mandate
which requires people 12 and under 12
and older to show vaccination proof for
indoor dining and indoor fitness and
indoor entertainment
um well how do you pronounce that please
oh donnie who's pop and rest pop and
restaurant was a successful business
that had been open for 10 years in times
square manhattan its owner now says
comparing the clientele from pre-mandate
to when it kicked that kicked them about
two weeks ago our business is definitely
down 50 i'm going to say 60 percent
there's just no people coming into the
restaurant they have the fear of being
asked for vaccines we don't have the
money here to survive without the help
of our landlord who has been very
supportive and has been giving us breaks
on the rent but without our landlord we
would not be in business he conclude
concluded adam what do you think about
this
well the the most striking thing to me
and and look i i generally want to get
gerard's uh
perspective on this because he's from
new york and has been back a few times
but the the the 12 and older thing is
what sticks out to me and i'm not i'm
not defending mandates let's not even go
there i don't think anyone should be
mandated to get the vaccine
but if there were going to be a mandate
you know
18 plus 21 whatever but 12 year olds how
old's tico
nine he's nine okay
like we're talking about kid i don't
even think kids are even available to
get the vaccine is that fill me in on
that yeah that's why tico will go to
casa d'angelo instead of any restaurant
okay so i mean it's a little extreme
what's going on in new york right now i
don't you would just ignore this idea
okay you were just in new york and you
were doing your uh comedy tour tell us
what it's like okay so uh i was in new
york and i posted a secret show for
anybody that follows me on instagram you
know i said secret show in new york and
people ended up being a little pissed
off at me when i dm when they dm me and
i told him where it was because it
wasn't in the city i kind of made it
seem like it was in the state but it was
actually half hour outside the city
specifically because of this
specifically because of the vaccine
mandate specifically because um
you know me and a few other i want to
give a big shout out to chrissy maher
and i want to give a big shout out to
caroline miljavik two people that don't
have the type of career and clout to
take the stand that they're taking but
they've decided even though you know i
believe they're both actually vast they
decided that they're not going to
they're both facts i believe so i don't
know but but i believe that they are and
but they've decided that they're not
going to force their
audience audience to you know show
medical proof to come see them perform
so i am supporting them and i did the
same thing long story short we had 190
people at the show on on friday night
190 people you figure it's a two drink
minimum the drinks are about 15 bucks
each 30 40 bucks easy per head what's
190 times 40 was that like seven grand
my calculator 190 times 40 yeah 75 8
grand a little shy of eight grand eight
eight grand in two hours yeah we made
this place in annual eight grand in two
hours you think these you think these
restaurants could use that you think a
club in the city after being 18 months
could have used eight grand on a friday
night that we earned them you know and
there's way bigger acts than me out
there that can do five six hundred
people easy yeah i mean we did 190
people on a secret show so thank you to
everybody that came out it was really
dope it was a fun show um and cool with
like nelson figueroa and uh andy chavez
and all those guys that do the pro-am
stuff also but the point i'm trying to
make is that's eight grand out the door
that for my entire life for 10 years of
doing comedy yeah that's eight grand
that goes to some somebody in midtown
that's eight grand it goes to somebody
in the village that's eight grand that
goes to somebody you know that that's in
the city now that eight grand went to
somebody in nanuet
so
multiply that by how many different acts
multiply that by you know how many
different people that have left to come
to florida i had a guy that was in town
yesterday you met him fernando a lot so
shout out to fernando lasso we have oh
yeah hilarious son with all the stories
the number one singer in equities
by the way a little bit at the house
yeah
he's coming to the birthday party by the
way let me tell you so mo you know how
sometimes you hear stories and you're
thinking it's fabricated so he starts
telling a story mario's sitting there
you were there the night before right
till what time one o'clock in the
morning kai heard some stories that he
will never reveal to anybody because
those were very private stories that
night was did you hear some stories you
were surprised by yesterday look at
guy's face right there more than i would
have thought
anyway so he's from ecuador and we had a
chance to meet his wife beautiful wife
very happy for for these two uh we go
back 22 years maybe i'm going to bring
him on the podcast to tell some stories
here pretty soon but he says uh i said
so we started talking to vaccination
thing i said so he says yeah they're
eventually going to mandate it for
travel anyways and they're going to
eventually man people are going to have
to get the vaccine anyways no matter
what happens because in ecuador here's
how it works no no no no no no no no so
he was that time of vaccine conversation
right so wiggins
gets cornered hey either take it or
don't take it i love what draymond green
said draymond green comes out and he
tells the story and he says are we
really talking about force isn't this
america
don't you have the freedom and then
lebron changes position on a little bit
lebron is kind of like hey if they want
we me my wife and our family we decided
to get the vaccine but it's the
individual's choice to do what they want
to do and he knows because kyrie's not
going to agree with them draymond all
these guys but wiggins ends up last
minute getting
the vaccine right and he has to now he
can now get paid on the home games all
this other stuff
the amount of pressure some of these
guys are getting you wonder if the small
timers are eventually going to be
wiggins is not a small timer this is a
guy that's making 20 a year this is not
a guy that's making a million dollar
contract or half a million this is a 20
million year contract not a superstar
but i would say he's a star he's a guy
that said 19 18.9 points a game last
season quietly he does his part
how much more you think this pressure is
going to get to people or do you think
the people standing up is going to win
eventually do you think the people in
america standing up are eventually going
to be like listen this is it stop it's a
little too much
let it go we're not doing this anymore
especially after newsom just announced
in the state of california
that kids above the age of 12
uh kids 12 to 18 have to be vaccinated
or else they can't go to school and new
york just announced if a mother this is
a story that just popped up if a mother
is pregnant she has the baby and if
she's not vaccinated she can't take the
kid home until she gets vaccinated let's
verify the story kai because i read the
story a couple days ago but when do you
think the tipping point is for people to
say you know what i give up i'll get the
vaccine or do you think people are going
to stand up
well
what is the survival rate right now
i think that should be something that is
celebrated and it's not
the damn survival rate is what it's like
okay so they say 700 000 deaths in the
united states or whatever
43 million cases of which five percent
the leading cause was coveted exactly
adam stop oh my gosh what's going on
around here that's why he's going to mr
olympia right so look how strong he is
you're a little strong yeah so but go
ahead we're listening so 330 million
people right and 700 000 which which one
death is too many for sure yeah but
we're not talking about everything else
and we're also not solving for
immortality right it's not become
nonsensical hey let me tell you
we all know doctors and you know what
they say people die every day yeah and
it's not being insensitive by saying
this
but we should be
out of this by now
okay you got israel you got all this
other stuff
that these are real stats yeah and the
fact that we're not celebrating the fact
that hey we're we're actually turning
this thing around yeah the survival rate
is this we also know like if you're
older and this and that we've already
talked about it like if your parents get
it it makes sense
you know if you're obese probably should
go get it because this is one of those
things that contribute to covet or
whatever yeah
we are in a place
where people are talking about mandating
something that you have 99 chance of
surviving
this is [ __ ] well yeah the the to
answer pat's question
you know
when
what's the tipping point man it
this is all a stress test at some point
why would they ever stop we haven't
stopped them you know like why would
they ever stop doing what they're doing
what why would they ever not implement
what they want to do next like what what
incentive have we given these people to
say man i tell you what this is the line
in the sand and if you cross this line
whatever happens next was your decision
we they keep pushing they keep pushing
they keep pushing and we [ __ ] and we
moan but we don't do anything
we we do nothing we do nothing of
consequence they say do what i tell you
to do or else and then they back it up
they take people's jobs away from them
the nurses what do we do what what's up
with that yeah i mean
like how cold is that man like we all
know are a nurse
why are they getting rid of these people
you were a hero you you were the person
that went through and saved people
and now you're just kicked to the curb
america you need to wake the hell up man
like that's cold-blooded like that's not
okay i think i think people the you know
the the
people got to do their own research and
feel comfortable about it talk to your
doctor talk to the people and i say talk
to both sides of the aisle not just one
side i'm a i'm a guy that's always like
when we uh decide to do something with
the company right and i'll say in the
meeting we'll send the board and i'll
say guys be the devil's advocate tell me
why this is not gonna work so don't sell
it
sell the opposite side right be the
devil's advocate guys will say well what
if such and such happens and then i try
to win those arguments and we as a group
try to win the and then we get stuck on
a question i'm like oh shoot
yeah you're right okay so guys what's
the salute what do we do if this happens
then you get stuck right so don't just
make a decision on one side or the other
side you know if you're somebody that's
like there's no way i'm going to take
the vaccine have you done the research
and there's some people that are like
i'm not going to take the vaccine you
know i'm going to take the vaccine have
you done the research against it just go
get educated i think i posted something
on twitter yesterday i said uh inflation
is calling the causing the dollar store
to be a two dollar store uh and then i
said uh some other thing on the second
one i remember what the second one was
and the third one was
you know uh censorship is causing us to
be too careful with what we talk about
because everybody's getting offended go
a little lower go a little lower go a
little lower
go a little lower right there inflation
has turned the dollar store into a two
dollar store low interest rates have
created a climate of fake success
censorship is creating an environment of
extremely sensitive people who only want
to hear things they agree with keep your
eyes and ears wide open i mean just pay
attention to what's going on absolutely
confirmation bias is huge right now it
is it's in it's in a in a big way so
we're going to see what's going to
happen but let me ask you
with my mic issue i don't know if we
address this but
the cookie cutter approach there's
different
strokes for different folks like
if you've there's been reports out there
there's an irela israeli study out there
that shows if you've had kovid
the immunities that you've built up over
uh over time are potentially even better
six times better yeah than getting the
vaccine well according to project
veritas that pfizer is aware of that as
well but everybody should know that
they're aware of it if i get a cold or a
flu do i not have antibodies
true shea and then you know this delta
variation certainly seems a lot more
dangerous than 100 than the original
variant and then
look
if you're gonna actually
there's people out there
that don't believe in the covid
there is a contingency i don't believe
it i don't think there is
slowing down how extreme it is i don't
think and if they want to live their
life
and just not want to get a vaccine
because they for whatever political
issue
or for whatever let me know what
percentage of people don't believe covet
is real
i think
i think what percentage believe code is
not in the united states yeah
what percentage doesn't believe covet is
really but the problem is whatever
number i give those are the loudest
[ __ ] no that's not true though
that's not true though
maybe one person have you ever watched
uh jordan klepper do his uh
entertainment
name one person one person of influence
today name me adam one person of
influence today that says covert is not
real one person i i don't know about
people of influence but that's their
odds
but that's allowed because there's
people out there let me say this let me
qualify this and then i'll throw this
out there for you guys there's people
out there who just say it's the flu
it's just a bad flu or it's just a flu
okay and for people of us that have had
you just change the door that's two
different things so there's tears
to what people say and i agree with you
there's people that say
covet is not real it's fake a year ago
how many people were there
a ton yes right yes or no a year ago a
year ago is what august of uh october
not october i would probably say more
june a lot of people said use that word
like scandals
that's that's not gonna do it depends
sometimes nothing to do with that part
how many how many people have been fired
for getting the vaccine
what does that mean there's people
getting fired for not getting it how
many people are getting fired for
getting it
why would you get fired for getting why
would you get fired for not getting it
i see what you did there but uh i think
that's the exact opposite of mentality
that they're trying to uh
my question today
the thing is you're trying to you're
trying to say it's it's a both sides
thing right i mean that's the idea what
i'm saying so clarify i mean i'm just
saying that they're trying to take a
cookie-cutter approach to this and like
you said you got to consult with your
doctor you have to make a decision
that's best for you
definitely don't believe in mandates
yeah and
but it is real
but but what i'm saying to you is name
me one person and there's no one so this
is any credibility this is what you
should get out there and say it's not
real so i can't name that person okay so
when did when did the let's just go to
the guy that's the biggest conspiracy
guy let's just say alex jones no no not
him go to trump let's just say trump's
the guy that's the most anti you know
left establishment that they don't like
right sure did he get the vaccine
did he tell people to get the vaccine
yeah kind of he did he did it's not kind
of he did so what i'm saying to you is
where i'm going with this is ain't no he
could be more vocal ain't nobody
how loud does he have to be as loud as
[ __ ] possible that's like saying like
lebron james has to talk as loud as
possible
he said it one time
did trump create the vaccine maybe maybe
he respects your choice
maybe he respects for you to have a
choice sure that's fine and he got it
and he says i took it do it go ahead and
do it like imagine somebody does
somebody need to be louder to force you
to get married
uh
louder to give no i've been why why
though how come you're not married how
come you're not married how come i'm
married how come you're not married it's
a choice you chose that to be it's a
pure choice it's your life
so if that's your life the same thing
with him he wants to say there's a
choice so i don't i'm cool with the
choice thing i'm not no you said he
needs to be louder he doesn't how about
this how many people have gotten sick
and died because they've taken the
vaccine versus how many people we don't
know i've gotten sick and died because
they were unvaccinated okay to say that
it's equal and to give me the we don't
know
i think there's a lot of answers there's
literally no way to know yeah those
numbers aren't there's no way to know
yeah those numbers what does that mean
you can't predict the future how do you
know whether or not if you got this is
one of the things that they're doing
which is nonsensical well he got it so
he's he's not as sick as he would have
been how do they know how could they be
here
here's the other part so for example
steroids let's talk about steroids we're
kind of talking about it yesterday right
yep there was a there was a book back in
the days they had edition one second of
them steroid bible i don't know what it
was 2000. something like that and it was
like first second third fourth edition
so we would buy them we would read it
right
and there was another book that was
written on steroids called ageless man
right i don't know who wrote it but some
guy wrote on ageless man and they tested
this on a rat
how as a man gets older the negative
consequences of your testosterone level
being below 240 or 200 it's actually not
healthy for you correct and your
testosterone level needs to be higher
not 1200 but it needs to be four to 600
for you to be able to perform day-to-day
activities and it's not even sex by the
way it's just completely like for your
bones to be stronger he's making this
argument right okay
how many years of history do we have on
steroids and side effects of steroids
probably about a hundred okay think
about that we got about 100 years of
research on steroids right we know
what's good we know not what's not good
so when you say
how many people are yeah how many people
are versus how many people are not
we only have one year of research since
last november 11 months yeah so so so to
say that you have to know the flip side
of the argument is well let's wait 10
years well let's wait five years well
then somebody may say what is the right
amount of research okay so but another
person may say uh so the conspiracy of
oh they're trying to put the microchip
whatever in there okay now that's that's
the stuff that just gets a lot of views
and you say things like that whether you
believe that or not that's the
conspiracy side what percentage of that
is true or not say one percent meaning
given the credibility of what it is fine
you want to put one percent go for it
it's not the chip side but the flip side
of it is saying hey you know what i'd
rather take the risk and i'll get it go
for it go ahead and do it i'm i'm good
with that no problem go ahead and do
there's a lot of things we put in our
body that don't we don't fully know
what's going on there's a lot of stuff
that we do
but still adam
it's the person's choice okay so can i
pick up right on that word you just said
choice i'm right with you on that
totally agree with you yeah i i was we
started off the show saying that i was
at this oslo freedom forum yesterday
again i'm talking to uyghurs who are in
in in uh re-education camps in china
nigerians are being murdered by this um
sars unit is what's going on people from
venezuela people from all over the world
who have been taking their freedoms away
from them and i asked them their story
what's going on and the last question
that i asked everybody and you think
this would be a very easy question to
answer at a freedom forum and it was the
most question that they were like oh wow
that's a good question oh maybe think
about it people were there fighting for
freedom i said
um
what does freedom mean to you that was
the last question i asked after doing a
five minute interview and every single
person was like huh
well there's no way people took their
time with that i swear to god you'll see
the footage they were man it's a good
question like
people they're speaking about freedom i
know [ __ ] and then after they hemmed
and had and they thought about it the
most
universal common answer was it's about
choice yeah it's about having options
and whether it's the choice to
marry who you want yeah
and and the second thing is
whether you agree with me whether you
don't agree with me whether you agree
with the vaccine that you have the
choice and that's the one thing that a
lot of people these countries don't have
they don't even have the ability to
question their government and they don't
even have the ability to say well i
don't know jerrod i don't think so well
yeah pat we're good
well they don't have that right
no i don't think we are though okay i
don't i don't think we're heading down
that road
we're not iran we're not north korea
that's where these people are living not
yet but we can i can show you
specifically where we're getting close
to that and that's actually why i want
to push back on pat a little bit
because when you you know you talk about
the microchips and the stuff so when
that when people talk about that
scandemic you use that word and the
microchips and these and these
conspiracies you lump everything
together into this idea that anything
outside of what's being reported in
mainstream media is is this this crazy
eccentricity that that takes it to crazy
time there's lizards living underneath
antarctica sometimes it is sometimes
it's real sometimes the the you said it
a couple episodes back the paranoid are
those who survive okay if you don't
think that there is some sort of goal to
have some sort of digital passport some
sort of tracking system involved you're
not paying attention okay if you don't
think that there's some sort of social
score coming our way that is already in
effect in china you're not paying
attention okay and if you don't think
that this is an obedience test if you
don't think especially after that
episode that pat put up yesterday with
what we know that the moderators are
doing behind the scenes at these major
social media conglomerates then guys you
are just not paying attention and to
your point as far as us being around us
not not to get off topic merrick garland
who was
nominated to be a supreme court justice
united states and is now in the biden
administration essentially just
weaponized the fbi to go after anybody
okay who has had any sort of opposition
to critical race theory and education
all right he sent a memorandum to the
fbi asking them specifically to treat
opposition to critical race theory and
um
quote-unquote vaccine hesitancy okay
which which you know is this this broad
term for questioning anything that's
official narrative okay they're treating
people that disagree
with
our elected
you know administration
as political dissidents
that is this that is the very precipice
of the slippery slope all right we
already knew we already know that obama
weaponized the irs that is not up for
debate that's not a conspiracy that was
confirmed that should have been one of
the biggest conspiracies since nixon
everybody knows it happened nobody cares
for some reason he weaponized the irs
against his political opponents now his
vice president's administration
is
publicly weaponizing the fbi against
political opponents
that's a problem that is a slippery
slope okay so while i understand and i
agree we're not north korea we're not
iran i think that we can become it so
much quicker than anybody gives any sort
of credence to
i i hear your point i i i also think
you're right on being paranoid and i
appreciate you saying well you know it
could happen it could happen
in my humble opinion i've just seen what
true tyranny looks like pat came from
iran i think it's hyperbolic to even
assume we're anywhere even close to it
bro that's just my point okay again i
just tried to tell comedy and i couldn't
do it inside of a city no you chose to
do a secret show you could have done it
in and i could oh donna hughes i could
not absolutely not
absolutely not i could not have
i could i would i would have they they
would have made it it was actually
illegal for me to earn money bro they
they
we just talked about the new york
restaurants
or a freaking mandate for something that
you have 99 chance of surviving
i mean what the hell are we doing what
are we talking about right now and at
the end of the day what is the
definition of being an american
this country was former well you can
actually come here and what's great is
that we actually have like these
debates or whatever we want to call it
but we can walk out of here and still be
cool yeah we respect each other's
opinion and stuff like that like they
want to take it away yeah they want to
take it away by force they don't want
you to speak at what point if you live
in new york city do you say enough's
enough i mean if you're like dude many
are saying it exactly many are so that's
the beauty of living in america again is
saying you know what yeah moving to
florida or i'm going here i'm going
there for now so adam let me ask you
you know
one day you're going to have a family
right that's the plan one day you'd like
to have a family one day by your choice
we're not going to force you i just want
you know don't force it yeah we're not
going to tell you go
we're going to be i've almost been you
know i've been forced into marriage
before it didn't work out it's not a
good strategy yeah we like choice but if
you're open to arranged marriage i like
i wouldn't mind doing an arranged
marriage with you i got some people
anyways
so yeah let's go back to it you get
married you have kids okay god willing
yeah god willing that happens you have
kids okay
your level of uh paranoia will change
i'm sure when you have kids yeah let me
explain to you how it works like
uh
senna looks at me and she gives me these
eyes and she goes like this
and she kind of goes like this with her
hair and she takes these pictures and
all i think about is oh my gosh some
guy's going to go crazy over there
how the hell am i going to fight off
that guy you know what senna did the
other day
so somebody said something to send on
school you know what she said to the kid
she said
you know my brother's big and strong and
he will punch you in his face
i assume he's talking about billy yeah
he's worried about jenna she's gonna
have two six foot five brothers and a
dad with a million dollar car what do
you possibly do to impress that girl and
big ass uncles yeah that's right yeah
can you imagine so i said i sat there
i'm like
by the way honestly like for a moment i
was not in the conversation everyone's
talking i disappear i'm in la la land
is her boyfriend and i'm like what's
going to happen 15 years down the road
so he comes in
by the way she's 15. so she could very
easily and she's doing cheer right now
she's singing a cheer the other day of
her school i'm like oh my gosh she's
pretty she puts the stuff on and she
does the spike i mean she's 15 she's
five but she'll be 15 in no time
what just happened
what i'm saying to you is ten years down
the road you think that then i think
about dylan i think about tico like i'm
doing a parent-teacher conference
my level of paranoia for that is higher
today than when i was 29 years old when
i was 27 my paranoia was less the moment
i got married paranoia increases because
of a different lens
then you have the first kid your wife's
pregnant second then you have different
paranoia then you have your age you know
parents age all of that stuff adds up i
think the biggest thing is when a person
who lacks any paranoia that something
catastrophic can happen to this country
you you you will get caught and when you
get caught it's not going to be fun
because
sometimes in life almost you know in
your mind you're like i can fix any
problem i can fix any issue i'm good i
can fix this okay
there's certain problems you can't fix
you have cancer you can't fix cancer
there's certain problems you cannot fix
and there's different forms of cancer
one form of cancer is health the other
form of cancer is when it gets into
politics politicians and the other form
of cancer is when these politicians are
able to get into universities and
schools and then they get to the kids
the side effects of overcoming that
cancer is 40 years yeah it's not two
years bro generation it's 40 cuba is
still effed up till today how many
decades has it been one cancer goes in
iran
1978 79 that cancer is still there
43 years later and nobody can do nothing
about it and iran signs a contract with
china for 24 years for 400 billion
whatever the number is that cancer is
going to be there for another 25 years
that's sev that's 70 years of a cancer
so
there needs to be pushback there needs
to be i can think for myself there needs
to be let me think about it there needs
to be let me get back to you there needs
to be that notion to the government the
government needs to be held a little bit
more accountable and not like hey you
don't answer what i do in my life i
appreciate the feedback thank you for
doing your job so that is the only
concern because so
say for instance these guys this whole
new world order stuff what percentage of
new world order do you think is
conspiracy theory what percentage in new
world or do you think it's real what do
you think
yeah
gerard would know the odds i'm asking
you no no i'm asking you i don't but
this is not something that i'm well
versed in i've heard of it peripherally
and ninety percent of it has been from
the last person i'm going to go to is
gerard i'm not gonna go to gerard i'm
actually not gonna go to gerard okay
when you think about kai how old are you
kai
84 23 going on 60. okay you're 23 years
old 23 years old when you think about
the word new world order what do you
think about
i think about overreaching of government
and the combination of technology and
the the
big social media companies okay cool so
i mean just look at what happened
yesterday could we do anything or say
anything
like eric was saying his girlfriend was
freaking out because she couldn't get a
hold of her family and paraguay because
what's up was down like
as much as we're relying on this and the
infrastructure and they're all
together and on the same server talk
about not being anti-fragile that we
talked about the other day too so
super vulnerable if countries unite
if governments unite and their ideas are
now i would like to be the secretary of
whatever for the european division
and the you know leader of the world is
going to be elected as this person and
if that if we go in that direction like
an eu except happens to the world minus
china and couple other places
you don't have another place to go
you do not have another place to go when
you said if [ __ ] hits the fan people in
new york can go where they can go to
florida they can go to tennessee people
in california can go where they can go
to arizona they can go to texas but what
if everything becomes the same then
where are you gonna go so that is my
only concern i want everybody to be
competing i want you to compete to read
the content to come in here so that a
fan is going to say you know adam's
commentary is weak and i want you to
read those comments and go back and say
screw you
you know johnny69 i'm going to kick your
ass on the next podcast and i'm going to
come with some value like and i'm like
damn look at adam brought that
competition gets all of us to be like
upping up our game these guys got to get
better with the software kai's got to
get better at spelling hardy right we
all have to
figure out ways on how to improve but if
the moment the government doesn't have
to improve
go ahead say something what are you
going to do about it nothing because i
don't have to yeah i'm not going to dmv
and it's like i'm not with them
real quick these are the same political
officials who did not get a pay cut
while everybody else did
not one damn person said you know what
i'm not taking no pay
because my people in my district
that i'm shutting down
that i'm voting to shut down right they
didn't do this [ __ ]
and i'm pissed off at all of them
because of that because how many people
do we know small business owners that
have not recovered
you know there's people that are
homeless there's people that have like
literally no hope
that's the freaking problem
and then you have these talking heads on
on the news and this and that just
striking fear in every person
people are scared still
and like pat said you know like these
times do build up strong leaders strong
men look what they're doing right now
they don't want strong men in the media
they want weak ass dudes
they want you know what i'm saying
we should be pounding our chests man
toxic you know toxic masculinity please
call me that
screw you
you know what i'm saying
i'm a freaking american i've traveled
i've been to china i've toured china
i've been to shenzhen shenyang beijing
shanghai all that [ __ ]
and it is not the same
when i read robert spaulding's book that
[ __ ] is real
they're trying to damage america right
now and it is a problem
and people of all races are so soft
stop and just read some freaking books
some real [ __ ]
not just the little clips and think how
manipulated
these people that we know on social
media get just by seeing like a little
snippet they're gonna see five seconds
of like let's just call it what it is
they'll say five seconds of trump or
whatever and then just go on a rant
they won't even educate themselves
and what you said about like iran and
all this other stuff americans need to
understand what that means but because
of the fact that we don't travel outside
of this country
we don't know and we're so arrogant
i've traveled over 40 countries i've
been to cuba i've been to guantanamo bay
you know i've done a lot of travel and
you know how many times i was in
istanbul turkey
and i get a call real quick i'll tell
the story i get a call from
the front desk they said mr heath you
need to leave now
excuse me yes u.s embassy is there to
take you to the airport you know what
just happened some of mine just been
assassinated
i had to grab my [ __ ] and get on four
different flights to get my ass home
i
landed in houston
and hugged a customs agent
i hugged him
you know why
because i was scared
and i was proud to be back
we need that man people need to like
understand what being american is dude
like you don't know what it feels like
to be in another country and you have no
choice i've been to venezuela i've been
to colombia i've been in all those
places man this [ __ ] is different yeah
so we need to wake the hell up like this
is like don't just like gerard says
there's a lot like quit just being in
this la la land and
oh everything will be fine like it will
never happen quit using the word
conspiracy
because we all saw the video when biden
and pelosi and all these other people
said oh there's no mandate there's no
mandate what they're doing now
and people voted for that
people should be pissed
they should call them out and they're
not because they got the confirmation
bias and they're just like well i don't
want to sound like you know i voted for
this no you need to raise your freaking
hand and say yeah you know i voted for a
bad policy
my bad i won't do it in i won't do it
again
that's the problem but we need to say
this [ __ ] it's okay you voted for him
good
you use your american right you voted
for it but you didn't and you had the
intention you didn't think voting for
this president that this was going to
happen i'm not saying that i don't think
any of us are but that's what's
happening and we need to wake the hell
up
i'm tired of this [ __ ]
yeah i think uh i mean that's incredible
incredible i know you've told me that
that is the uh turkey story it's
incredible man i mean it's nuts i can't
imagine what was going through your mind
but you know i keep going back to that
old parable right like all it takes for
evil to prevail is for good men to do
nothing that's all it takes you know at
some point somebody has to be the one
somebody has to be the guardian on the
wall and like you said i mean
we're kind of in it it's a good thing
it's a good thing that all of us in this
generation wanted to be nicer to each
other that we wanted to be more
empathetic that we wanted to say you
know what i understand where you're
coming from i empathize with your pain
and i'm sorry but it went too far
and our kindness was 100
taken as a weakness they weaponized our
empathy against us now we need a little
bit of our grandfather in us now we need
a little bit of john wayne to come back
and say you know what i don't care if i
hurt your feelings i care if you listen
what i said because if you're true in
your intentions if you're true at heart
if you're not an actual racist if you're
not actually a sexist if you're not
actually an [ __ ] then you shouldn't
be afraid to say anything that you want
to say and you shouldn't be afraid about
how it's going to be manipulated
i am who i am and i'm going to be who
i'm going to be and anybody can take
what i say like you said we speak so
much and so often on here anybody can
take a three second you talked about
this on rogan anybody could take three
to five seconds manipulate it and put it
out there and then it's up to the people
all right to go back and watch for
context but i actually when i when i
talk to people when i listen to people i
think that they're doing that i think
that people don't like being lied to
people don't like being misled i think
that this era is going to be one defined
by authenticity you're not going to be
able to hide look at kamala harris look
at kamala harris she's hated and then
they went on the view and they tried
saying this because of her gender
because of her race and it's not it's
because she's as fake as you could
possibly be and you can't be fake
anymore they're going to find out who
you are they're going to know who you
are they're going to know what your
intentions are the i trust the people
and that's the big difference between i
think
the the kind of you know this this
freedom movement versus this globalist
movement is i trust my neighbors
i trust them i trust my neighbors i may
not agree with you i may not like you
but i trust you i trust that i don't
need to make a law to say don't block a
fire exit because if there's a fire
you're going to get your ass out the
room i trust that you don't want to get
burnt alive i trust people i trust at
people's ability to be kind and be good
to one another and it doesn't have to be
adjudicated doesn't have to be made a
law because when we make laws and we're
addicted to authority and we're addicted
to control what people don't understand
is what that law means if you make a law
all right you put a mask mandate out
there now the intention might be i'm
keeping people safe
well that might look good at first but
take that two steps forward what if
somebody says no
what it what happens if somebody says no
well now you have to get somebody to
come and force them out of the
establishment and if they say no to
being forced out of an establishment out
of a public place what happens a cop
comes what does it cost like what we saw
happen in australia that should have
that lady getting there you go strangled
at so somebody where i'm at somebody is
getting kidnapped being arrested is
being kidnapped at gunpoint that's what
that's what actually being arrested is
so you're having somebody you're so
afraid you're so afraid of your neighbor
at this moment that you're willing to
have an authority
send somebody to kidnap them at gunpoint
come on man so ultimately
is your point no mandates
my point is
that at this moment in time okay
that you should allow people
to live their life as they see fit
that you should allow people the the
wherewithal and the personal agency to
protect themselves and their family and
run their business and life accordingly
that's what i'm saying that is exactly
what i'm saying now if you want to do
something like new york do something
like new york fine but then when
everybody leaves
don't start taking federal money don't
start taking don't you know you know
what i'm saying like don't when when you
run out of california
and then you go to texas because
everybody
i've got a lot of special gifts in my
life yesterday i come in
gerard got me the limited edition kamala
harris bobblehead i mean there's there's
only a few of these and i just want to
publicly thank you for this this special
gift you got to get one that's right
next to my desk it's i put it right next
to my desk does it laugh
it actually does it laughs it laughs
yeah it's a new one that we have and we
have a special one that's uh you know i
know adam
it's it's mine it's once you know this i
have it yeah you can but we're gonna
we're gonna get we're gonna get a
voucher one for you here pretty soon so
okay so this was great great discourse
here going back and forth appreciate
everybody's commentary on this let's go
to the next topic look we know what
happened yesterday it's all over the
news facebook facebook whatsapp whatsapp
uh uh instagram everybody's texting this
your facebook you text me first guys is
my facebook is it just me because you're
thinking maybe it's me it's like it's
the world that was sticking down
real quick to conspiracy theory
you noticed that i was at a conference
at the forum yesterday and at first
they're blocking me man it's all i knew
it they're on to me
and then uh it was the world
bro be fair you didn't believe i was
actually shadow band on instagram and
then you saw it what did you see tell
the world they don't like you they don't
like care they don't want you to be
heard
and maybe for good reason gerard
all right so let's let's talk about this
article from cnn okay facebook instagram
what's up goes down facebook's week just
went from bad to worse facebook and
saying what's up all suffered outage
midday monday we're aware that some
people are having trouble uh accessing
our apps and products facebook said on
twitter the outage came the morning
after 60 minutes aired a segment
in with facebook whistleblower francis
hagin claimed the company is aware of
its platforms are used to spread hate
violence and miso
misinformation and that facebook has
tried to hide that evidence
shares of facebook were down more than
five percent in midday trading monday
putting it on pace for its worst
trading day
in nearly a year now here's what's crazy
about it while this is going on
yesterday you're at that event i'm
interviewing a guy named sean spiegel
who's a whistleblower who used to work
at facebook as a moderator okay so he
went from a moderator of choosing the
regular things that's coming up you know
memes all this stuff then he gets
promoted to the next level where he
really saw the kind of videos that was
being put up by the way
i've never had a
warning at the beginning of an interview
where i personally come up and i say
don't watch this interview okay i'm
telling people do not
watch it because how uncomfortable and
disturbing this video is now
if you want to be aware watch the
interview but i'm telling you in advance
so we put a warning sign we put all that
stuff in this interview
we've have we ever done this before in
any interview we've never done this with
was this a pre-planned interview it just
had a crazy interview you called me i
was talking to him no meaning like did
you set this up weeks in advance or did
you say yo no no this was set up
facebook goes down get him on the line
it just so happened that it was
happening it was a coincidence okay
that's what i'm saying it was
pre-planned no no this interview is
supposed to go on in two three weeks
it's not scheduled to go out this week
david yes or no yeah correct this wasn't
this was just a complete coincidence
this is complete so yesterday i'm saying
so gerard comes out of nowhere and he
said he just got back from new york it's
bad do you mind if i sit in okay do you
mind if i sit in and listen to this okay
adam the stuff i heard my stuff like
it's this
he said the environment at this place as
a moderator his job is to look at
everything that's coming there's about a
thousand people that work this is a
company that was contracted out with
facebook that eventually they said we're
not gonna work for you anymore a company
that does 16 billion per year cognizant
technology solutions it's a 16 billion a
year company it's not a small company
anyways he says in our facility there
was a thousand of us working there it
was two bathrooms that they had there
there was what did he say was always on
the wall he says you know people would
poop and pee in the air in the woody
color in the sink yeah they were so
meant no no no they were so mentally
broken they were so mentally broken that
uh after weeks on the job people would
like start smearing feces on the wall
and like
pretty nasty yeah and by the way that's
not let's just say that's a two that's a
two the stories he says ghost david
would you agree i'm not even going to
tell you the stories because it's so
uncomfortable yeah it's very graphic
very very as as graphic as you can
possibly what's the reasoning behind
this so these guys aren't enslaved they
can choose to work here right no no no
it's very very odd very very odd dynamic
let's explain it
well it's extremely uncomfortable he
says he says at any point somebody's
sitting there your job is to watch the
video and then send a report to facebook
this video needs to be taken down and
facebook comes back and says no that
facebook that video is going to stay up
because this is a private group and it's
not a public group and it's only a
private group so therefore we're going
to leave this up yeah and he says
facebook's position was the more videos
like this we keep up the fbi and cops
are gonna be able to find the bad guy to
go get him and the guy's like that's not
what's happening and then i said let me
go a little bit deeper with this by the
way since people are doing this watching
videos all of a sudden they're thrown up
he says at any point people were
throwing up at their workplace he says
it smelled it was horrible it was
horrific terrible situation at this
workplace what they're doing because
somebody has to watch his videos so
anyways this happens we interview him
then facebook is down then we go live
with it yesterday i've never had this
many people message me about an
interview i did pat i'm having a hard
time watching this this is crazy and the
guy
is would you say he's part of the lgbt
he said he said he said he's um he made
a comment yeah he he is
he he's not by any stretch of the
imagination this is not a macca guy this
is not anybody that's far right this is
this is a guy who who um is an animal
rights activist and sympathetic to the
lgbt movement and that those were his
words
um
and
you know he cried in the interview we
started talking about animals and what
they were doing
what you know who's they people around
the world who yeah
apparently there's an entire look this
is snuff this is nothing more than no
this is a snuff this is snuff
and there's there's groups where people
go and they and they pay and they use
the facebook marketplace to pay for this
video i mean he described um
he he described bestiality he described
um forced incest he described um you
know animal cruelty while bestiality was
occurring i mean like really as by the
way when he said like like hell like
like what you would imagine would be
gerard i did not know what bistitoli
meant bestiality meant i i put on google
while he's talking bestiality yeah and
i'm like
close immediately yeah the stuff that
he's talking about no i'm not good um
and this is the reason why people
watching the videos are puking throwing
up going no bro if you hear the video
like there's one situation with a pig
yeah yeah that's put it like this yeah
it's when i walked in the office yeah
and i saw pat and gerard and they were
explaining this stuff
they were shook
i mean it was like it was it was very it
was very like this the vibe was there's
no reason to assume the guy's lying we
haven't verified it like we're still in
the process of verifying his claims
we're trying to get you know two or
three other people to verify it as well
to make sure that that what he's saying
is is not you know exaggerated in any
way so look take it anecdotally at this
point right this is one guy put one of
the clips put one of the clips you know
which one i'm talking about so i asked
him a question i say so do you can you
check anybody's uh uh
oh that's a whole separate
beyond and then it's like this was
insane this was crazy okay just watch
this go ahead and press play go ahead
and press play
is that the one
i say do you guys check instant
messenger
so you guys were able to see what's
being said in the instant messenger and
text messages or no yes also whatever we
post there and we're communicating you
see all of it yes absolutely
[Laughter]
everything that's communicated here if
you wanted to see all of it you can
easily see it yes and yes you have
access to who like
do is there levels of clearance on who
you have access to want to be able to go
see let me see if this one guy i don't
like let me see what he stands for i'm
going to go see what this guy's saying
to this person here could you do that or
was there limitations to what they sent
to you
no uh in the general queue there were
limitations where i was there were not
were you ever tempted to see something
hang on hang on we're higher up go back
a little bit go back a little bit go
back a little bit okay go ahead
go ahead were you ever tempted to see
some conversations of people that were
higher ups or no
i was tempted yes but not specifically
higher-ups uh i have to be honest
politics isn't my thing i was more
curious about seeing what my cousin was
saying up in georgia
so he's working there and he wants to go
see what his cousin says but he has
access to everybody but what he said was
politics weren't his thing yeah but the
place was the most politically he talked
about that he talked about that yeah
yeah and politics people were there
specifically because of their politics
and that to me was the most shocking
part i mean the the what he was saying
about the bestiality was was gross but
anybody that's ever had live league seen
the internet you know that this stuff's
out there and it's heinous this
the fact that anybody can have access to
anybody's whatsapp anybody's instant
messenger not stuff that was reported
dude not something that somebody
manually reports he could go search adam
sosnick's dms
pull it up and read them
see them you don't want no part of that
dude
i want some of them dms dude
it's
this is this is privacy okay there's a
part of it when he says i just care what
my cousin in georgia said it's funny
obviously meaning he could spy on his
cousin in georgia
but if he wants to see
what two senators are talking to each
other and they're you know if he wants
to see what anybody empowered to go back
and look at all their history you know
everything he can find that out and
that's facebook so this is not facebook
this is a third party facebook's given
access to that that's really crazy so
think about that third party
third party yeah so this is the general
queue so here's the question i asked
because because when i was with rogan
it's hillary clinton's servers if you
remember when i was with rogan rogan we
we talked about jack dorsey and he said
the uh i like jack he says i like what
he's doing and jack went on two times
the first time that people said you
didn't push him too hard he came back
and he pushed him a little bit harder
with some of the questions with his
general counsel there though i get that
but the part is when he said
you know jack wants twitter to be more
open he would like it to be two
different formats with twitter one is
like on the back end where you can say
free for all do whatever you want to say
he wanted two twitters he wanted two
twitters yeah so so for me
i go and i ask the one question i said
okay facebook like yesterday we haven't
even gone to what we think happened
yesterday that's really what we got to
get into because i got thoughts yeah so
i said so
let's let's give the guy the benefit of
the doubt they got sixty thousand plus
employees okay that doesn't count
contractors so i had another hundred
thousand contractors people that are
working outside but they're not w2
they're 1099 contracts that they're
working whatever the numbers let's just
say 60 000 employees
maybe he doesn't know what's going on
maybe maybe he doesn't know what's going
on
listen you got like i got stuff going on
here we got 40 employees but you guys go
out i don't even know where you guys
went i don't know what's going on so
imagine what 40 i don't know what's
going on you think you're going to know
what's 60 000. we got 16 000 17 000
insurance agents yeah in 150
offices nationwide you think i know
everything that's going on now so go to
60 000 employees because
could this be a part where when you're a
ceo at this level he's probably got 30
c-suite executives he's got 20 c-suite
executives
who were the people that knew
did they report up that the people at
the top know why is this content being
left up this is a compliance issue so
this leads to
yesterday facebook going down so why did
facebook go down let's let's talk about
possibilities i'll throw some out there
and then you give yours go ahead you
have a thought yeah before we get into
that more importantly you also asked him
about how does shadow banning work and
do they do they act you said i've been
doing this for a long time he admitted
he admitted to social engineering
there's videos pat said i've been doing
this for a long time in the videos
they'll rise they'll rise they'll rise
then they'll peter off but there's some
videos they rise they rise their eyes
and then they fall off a cliff is that
organic or he goes absolutely not that's
somebody saying that they don't want
this message out there and they just
turn it off they just turn it off they
said somebody's saying like one person
making that decision i said the same
thing who has that decision kind of
authority who has that power
not at his level he reports and gives
facebook what to do facebook chooses
what they want to do with and they can't
delete anything yeah they simply watch
and sent in
that's what his job is and then facebook
has to decide so on a couple of the
instances facebook left the stuff up and
he kept going back he kept going back he
kept going back he kept going back they
said no this is going to stay up we're
not taking this down
so yeah but facebook has to be aware
like the whistleblower story i know
we're gonna get into but facebook has to
be aware that
sean spiegel whatever his name is or
billy mcgillicuddy or john doe is gonna
be able to speak out about this
like this guy has no loyalty to facebook
at any point he can do an interview with
you he gets fired doesn't like his job
people are throwing up around him he
[ __ ] quits and now you can do like
how many there's a thousand people
working in a room and this is what
they're doing you're right how many of
them can speak out you're right has to
know that they're so arrogant i think i
think that they know that they can
control the narrative to such a level
right that they they know right they
know like look even in our minds
there's a little bit in all of us right
now they're saying man you know
we're we're really we're talking about
this stuff we're really going there
we're talking each one of us if we're
being honest we're saying look we're
doing it we're going for it man we hope
to we hope the listeners appreciate this
because we're we're all putting
ourselves out there what what what is
that what is that inside of all of us
because all of us know that these guys
are all holding it over us at all the
time when that guy said it pat asked
that question yesterday and i was
sitting in the back i said holy [ __ ]
this guy just admitted to social
engineering that's not moderation by the
way that's manipulation the way he said
it he says i said do you have a problem
with what they're doing on the left and
the right he says well on the right
there were people on the right that were
saying what were the stuff that they
were saying i asked some questions so
you think trump should be uh off of
facebook you think he should be off he
says well let me think about this one
here because on one end
if he was a regular person doing what he
was doing probably yes if he was a
regular person but if he's the president
and he's doing what he's doing in the
january 6th event yes he kind of went up
there and he's the one that started it
but later on that night at six o'clock
he did come and tell people go home and
i like this guy's like he's going
through the sequence on how he's
explaining it right
and then he says no i think he should
still be on and then he says i said what
were the people pushing on the right so
he's what did he say on the right left
no no the right the right was pushing uh
just being nasty bullying libtards
that's right so and then he said on the
left uh there's too much push on kids uh
being part of the lgbt lgbtq community
which which i support he says which i
support he supports the lgbt community
he says it's too big of a push amongst
kids and he says it's too much too big
of a push on transgender uh uh having
influence over kids and that's being
left out there and the segregation yeah
i said the left is they they don't want
to coexist there's too many people that
just they want they think there should
be two worlds by the way if you watch
this interview you'll say this guy's on
the left you won't say this guy's on the
right like if you watch this guy you're
not going to say oh you know he's a
supporter of you know center really
right i mean no i don't think he's
centered i'm gonna put this guy center
left because
there were still some error but but for
the most part he's trying to stay as
reasonable as possible yeah he was
trying to be as reasonable possible
very level-headed the craziest part of
the interview for people that haven't
seen it is how matter-of-factly he
answered these insane questions like
he's you know are we are we watching
like you know it was like a gotcha
question like are you guys listening to
our our uh messages yeah absolutely
yeah yeah yeah can can you search
messages from yeah no problem
so wait is is facebook turning off uh
you know viral content yeah yeah they
determine what messages they want out
like he was just so matter-of-fact it
was like it was like bone chilling how
matter-of-fact this guy was about the
social engineering in your opinion what
level of credibility does this guy have
one through ten in your opinion
i'm gonna give this guy seven seven
eight okay yeah
hey let me let me tell you yeah because
he doesn't have a bone to pick with
facebook he has a bone to pick he he's a
he's an animal activist his his main
goal was just to like show the animals
yeah no it's like it's it's all about
animal he saw uh one time they he saw a
video about oh so so i said what was the
most disturbing video he said
one time there was a video these two
boys no these two boys were taking the
iguanas from the tail and they were
smashing the iguanas on the ground so
hard and iguanas were having the scream
i've never heard any i never knew
iguanas could scream like that and
they're hitting the head and they did
this with different types of animals and
they would put it in their private
facebook group and that stayed on
silence and the lamb stuff she says like
iguana like it was so like
who who says so you have to know how
he's wired he's like let me ask you
without okay this is just a hypothetical
sick stuff that's going on yeah right
sick stuff without facebook without
social media
these [ __ ] sickos would be doing this
regardless
now they're doing it for the world to
see or for people to see
and maybe
maybe they could be held accountable for
their
heinous acts
is that maybe a good thing that you
could hold these people accountable
because there's people i've talked about
that i mean i know a buddy of mine he's
fine now i mean ironically he's a big
maga guy but this guy would put his cat
in the microwave as a kid about five
seconds i'm like what the [ __ ] are you
doing you [ __ ] weirdo yeah okay
um and then i was like dude this is what
are you doing like this isn't cool like
we're all you know we're 12 years old
like this isn't funny yeah haha like not
cool yeah okay but this is pre-social
media stuff this is minor whatever but
there's people that do this sick stuff
yeah no and as much as we're railing
against social media right now
maybe it's you know it's kind of like
shooting yourself in the [ __ ] sounds
like they're not their job isn't to
they're sending this to facebook they're
not sending the [ __ ] to the authorities
but if the authorities can see this kind
of stuff
again you guys got to watch the video he
brought up that claim and he was like we
need to bring this to the authorities
and then according to him he was like
facebook was like we don't need that
type of publicity we don't need that you
know like if the authority so facebook
doesn't want to be cop because if they
become cop oh yeah the the category of
the type of business they become changes
and you as the user lose trust in
community like even right now we talked
about the fact that the guy says they
can read every message what percentage
of the people that are listening are
kind of like oh so i'm going to make
sure i filter out those three things i
would say some people probably want to
play that's what i'm saying so i think
people are just going to carry on with
their lives well no no no but 10 is 10
10 is not a small number that's still a
big number so to me
when you see this okay let's go let's go
to what happened yesterday let's go to
what happened yesterday there's plenty
on this we got a few other stories i
want to touch up on as well and we've
got 31 minutes left 32 minutes left so
yesterday what really happened yesterday
let me tell you the different stories
that i heard
one of the stories was what that hey uh
somebody on the back end is uh uh
permanently uh
taking the facebook and instagram code
out i think barstool sports put it up
some twitter account academy put it up
and some of these other guys put it i
mean these are verified accounts these
are not like regular accounts that they
put it up and that went viral and that
got a lot of you saying maybe facebook
and instagram is permanently gone and
people are texting me what's gonna
happen if this thing's permanently gone
and twitter post a tweet which was
hilarious what did twitter say he says
uh uh we welcome all of you something
like that kai see if you can find that
twitter uh tweet
uh uh uh they they capitalized on this a
lot yesterday as they should yeah as
they should they said hello literally
everyone he got 3.2 million likes
773 000 retweets so
so one of them is okay somebody hacked
and they destroyed the code whatever
okay so that's not the case another one
is china was involved okay and because
of what happened to 60 minutes and so
china's coming out and saying hey
you guys better you know whatever okay
so that's that part the one that was
very interesting that to me really got
me thinking was the final one there's a
group of people that said facebook did
this facebook did this to themselves why
would facebook do this to themselves
facebook went
and cleaned house
with everything they had because of what
happened a couple weeks ago a week ago
with apple coming out and saying we're
going to take you off the platform with
facebook and instagram apple just
announced that a week ago and a week
later you come out and you do this maybe
they took it down
and they went
destroyed you know who knows
a bunch of these pages on the back end
and took a bunch of the things out and
some of the stuff that you can actually
go see to clean up their name because it
was down for quite a few hours it wasn't
like six hours it wasn't like 30 minutes
so it could be an internal thing that
happened uh now i don't know if that's
true or not but to think about that
thought would facebook all the scrutiny
they're getting this is what's happening
then another part is the fact that
you know the 60 minutes lady was talking
about what kind of content is being
staying up
another uh story was the fact that
facebook helped trump with election and
they don't want facebook to have the
kind of power in the next election
because they have so much power in
getting somebody elected so if there's
control on mainstream media the left's
only threat is what they don't have
control over which is facebook and mark
zuckerberg is not a yes guy
mark's not saying yes and they kind of
don't like that mark's not sitting there
saying yes we'll do this yes we'll do
that he's the only one that said you
know we'll see if we're going to get
trump at it but we're not permanently
banning trump we're going to have our
team that look at it twitter says what
we're permanently banning trump right so
facebook is a threat
to the left because facebook could help
the opposing party get elected maybe
they want a little bit more control some
want this thing to be more controlled by
the government because if the government
controls facebook it's over so imagine
if the government runs facebook would
you want that so anyways that's some of
the stuff i've heard i'll leave it up to
you guys gerard what do you think
happened yesterday based on some of the
articles you read i don't want to get
crazy in the conspiracies here but i
just i i think uh i think it's very very
the timing of things is very very
curious i it's becoming more and more
difficult for me to to consider
coincidences over the last 18 months to
two years it's you know coincidences
just seem to you know keep
keep piling up into into ways that that
increase power for the for the most
powerful amongst us it's amazing how
these coincidences keep keep funneling
into into their win column uh you know
china tightens uh political control of
internet giants is a story that
headlines abc news three days ago they
fly
38 38 flight fighter jets over taiwan
yesterday um there's a leak with cnn i
would on cnn
about facebook and then facebook goes
down snapchat goes down
um
you know whatsapp goes down six hours
tick tock's fine uh i i don't i don't
i don't see this all as being isolated
instances i see this all as being
somehow interconnected i think that
there are uh political games there are
machinations being played at levels that
that it's hard for normal people to
understand and to comprehend what's
happening on a global scale
i think the world is becoming very very
very small at the top of the pyramid and
i think that there's a lot of people
vying for control for that top and and
we're we're kind of seeing that
trickle-down effect down hit us that
that's what i think happens um and my
biggest takeaway was like while we're
joking and while you know we're all like
looking at our facebook and while we're
like wow this is you know people are
like get outside talk to each other my
whole thing is like man i can't believe
how easy it was to disconnect the world
i can't believe how easy it was to
disconnect everybody you know if they
did that and they took cell service away
what would we do like that's it what
would they what would we do for six
hours what could be done in six hours of
radio silence how much ground could be
lost
could could could you recover
six hours of radio silence
what what could be taken from you
that that's where my mind went through
my one went through was i am remarkably
under prepared for what i i think is an
increasingly freaking war that's what
i'm saying what could happen in six
hours six hours of radio silence how
much different could the world you come
back to be
and i i felt very helpless in in that
i'm completely and totally underprepared
for that eventuality
yeah well
to your point like what could happen i i
think you know we for for a few years
now maybe longer we've been hearing
about
antitrust and monopoly and
you know we got to break up facebook
they're too big too big to fail the
banks are too big everything that we've
heard for years with wall street
yesterday was pretty damn evident like
ironically twitter hello world yeah
because you had basically one source of
all right here's we could go to tell
your story when facebook owns facebook
instagram oh by the way shout out to
michael berry's uh option call on
facebook from two weeks back right
ironically
um it just puts things in perspective
like damn do we need to break up
facebook does are they getting too big
are they getting too clearly that is a
great question what do you think about
that that's all that's something that we
need to talk about
and then part b to that as i've also
heard
well the the whistleblower what was her
name again francis
hagin she had some pretty compelling
stuff if you haven't seen that interview
so someone said well yeah that you know
her interview the whistleblower
basically saying that facebook was sort
of like amplifying
stuff that was more divisive
controversial topics and it would push
it to the top of the algorithm and and
get you know that's that's how you would
make your ad money because it's so
engaging and all that stuff they said
because of her interview and the
whistleblowing
that they wanted to do something to draw
less attention away from her interview
and i said
i don't know about this a buddy of mine
i was like i don't know about that man
because i got to be honest with you i
was just kind of living my own life on
sunday watching uh tom brady do his
thing i didn't see the interview i
didn't hear about the interview
ironically so now
all i'm hearing about is the interview
because facebook went down
so why would they want to
plus the interview was to me like a big
nothing burger it was just 60 minutes
whatever it wasn't
it was a big deal but not that big of a
deal but now you know
all your platforms are going down for
six hours the whole world is now talking
about facebook that doesn't make sense
to me that would be sort of
counterproductive
if i were to go that route with your
buddy the pandora papers make more sense
to me the pandora papers make way more
sense vladimir putin goes shut it down
you know like i don't think the world
doesn't need to know about this so just
shut it all down do we think what so
what are the top three
reasons for this you're saying that it
was a hack china something like that a
data breach
facebook shut it down intentionally it
was just an accident i don't think this
doesn't seem coincidental what do you
think
do i think this was an accident like
accidentally this happened no i don't
think this is an accident do i think we
know for a fact what happened no do i
think facebook knows what happened
absolutely do i think facebook will
reveal to the world what really happened
zero chance so
everything else is until somebody on the
inside decides to come out and be the
next whistleblower to say what really
happened to facebook everything's going
to be speculation it's not going to be
my seat yeah this seat is warm for you
come sit down anybody from facebook
twitter please you know you you are
going to do you're going to be
remembered all right for what you do in
this world if you sit there and do
nothing again we talked about it if you
allow
if you do nothing all right that's all
evil needs to win all right come out and
and use the platform speak your truth
let the world know let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question
do you think the world's a better place
without facebook like you you're saying
like
i'll sting facebook and being gone do
you think well no go back to what adam
said before because that was a very good
question do you think facebook as it
currently exists is a good thing do you
think it should be broken up
well to me it's not about whether it's
broken up or not i i don't if if the
answer to the question is mark didn't
know yeah you need you need seven ceos
running companies
if mark didn't know that this stuff is
taking place yeah you need you need more
leadership to to do what they're doing
no question about it because it's too
big yeah because if that if that's the
case but if mark no so let's just say we
talked to mark mark did you know about
this i did not know about this no
problem you need to be broken up
you need more leadership how do you not
know about this how important is this
matt if this is true how important is it
to you mark very it is yeah so don't you
think as a ceo of the company you need
to be aware of something that's very
important to you yes so how do who who
screwed up here who needs to get fired
who didn't do their job is there enough
investment being made in people to watch
over this maybe right now you're only
putting one percent of the company's
revenue and two profits into it maybe
you need to increase that to three
percent if it's really important maybe
the amount of control needs to be
internal maybe they're so that's the
conversation i'm having that's purely a
business conversation for me if mark
didn't know but let's circle back to
what what you talked about earlier with
you know them being able to turn off
content and being able to shadow band
mark zuckerberg is not making that call
mark's not looking at what do you think
where's sheryl sandberg in all this and
what's the what's the screening process
for the people that put their finger on
the boat let me ask you a question so
you got to be very careful when you go
in there by the way
you got to be very careful if you're
going
people have to be very careful
complaining about that let me explain
because if we go in that route
complaining about that a little bit too
much who's the only other person
that is going to control that button i
don't think there should be a button
no no wait there needs to be a button
let me explain why there needs to be a
button the whole purpose of this guy if
there's no button those videos will be
live public to everybody yeah no so
there no that's that's that's not that's
not something you need bro let me put it
to you this way first time you saw
again we talked about this before first
time you saw extreme porn what did it do
to you
how old were you like it messes with a
kid when you see they're like what the
hell is this like you know how they say
smoking weed is is is okay if you try it
after 30 years old if you smoke weed too
early it's not good you do you it's too
early for you to start your kids
watching uh uh
faces of death
yeah and that's a great example that's a
great example [ __ ] was you know i
remember being like what 10 12 years old
like oh man like
you're seeing the faces of death we're
like what's that and then you see
someone getting shot i think some of
that
that movie with yeah cage uh six
millimeter do you remember them
yeah whatever the hell it was yeah snuff
films sure but if we're if we're jesus
if we're just talking about that binary
if we're talking about the binary
extreme of too much censorship or too
little censorship give me too little all
the time every single time and that
person who's posting that snuff
all right everybody in the world will
know who it is and we can point the
finger at them and we can say that's who
it is that's the background okay that's
the bad guy
that was my point
i learned about the broken windows
theory from rudy giuliani from our
conversation with rudy giuliani it is a
remarkably small
amount of people in the world that are
committing heinous crimes and all you
have to do is find that small the the
the you're saying do be the cop of those
bad guys no what i'm saying is is that
putting them in the shadows doesn't make
the snuff go away it just makes it be in
the shadows so
censoring other people under the guise
of somehow protecting the innocent is is
to me a horrible slippery slope i you
don't protect the innocent by silencing
people that that haven't done anything
wrong and you don't give
you don't know this is power okay i
gotta be honest i i i i tend to agree
with gerard yeah do you have like a
level setting
you know what i mean like
a certain setting they're saying like
yeah i want to see explicit content and
therefore like people can
you know okay well i want to see this
face of the day i want to see this stuff
well that's just what they have on the
movies you know but with the ugg
societies whatever what i think what
what the the moderator was saying more
than anything else is what these people
were doing was remarkably illegal this
was incest this was um um uh pedophilia
this was bestiality these things are in
fact illegal why isn't the company that
he works for
because you know we already said like
reporting report that to the authority
because they know what he said
that's why he was blowing he said these
people are such idiots they left their
license plate on there he says in many
cases they left the streets where they
lived on like you could go find these
guys like they're they're idiots he
could be a digital vigilante and say you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna create
this company i would guarantee you i
would bet you anything that this guy has
fantasized about being batman he knows
who these people are and going and yeah
he needs to be protected to your point
like seriously you gotta you gotta
expose the shadows with the sunlight you
gave that reference yeah these people
are going to be doing some wild [ __ ]
regardless yes and if they're they're
that foolish and that's sloppy to show
their home address or show their license
plate and they do it on facebook or
facebook live and they get caught i'd
rather them get caught than just
continue to do that you're saying leave
a hundred percent of the stuff on i'm
not saying a hundred percent i'm
definitely not saying a hundred percent
but these people are going to be doing
illegal weird crazy psychopathic stuff
regardless i'm not advocating for i'd
like to catch them there i'm not
advocating i think we're all on the same
page pat
was he afraid of his well-being
no
i don't think so at all really no i
would be scared [ __ ] yeah i would be
like
but but this is a guy that's got he's
not somebody that's married he's a guy
that's like listen i'm just i'm just
doing this because i want this stuff to
stop i'm not trying he says i don't want
money for this he says i don't wanna i'm
just trying to inner city
are these whistleblowers heroes
i think the different word for me is
necessary
okay i i don't know if i
feel comfortable saying heroes
or not there may be i mean for somebody
that's exposing this stuff they're
sitting there saying they are heroes
uh but i it's very easy in a situation
like this to blame everything on zuck
and dorsey it's very easy to do that for
us oh it's all zuckers zuckerberg
zuckerberg's fault that's only that's
what it is okay yeah fine yeah there's
some responsibility on the guy at the
top which is what everything rises and
falls on leadership fine yes got it
and then there's some responsibility on
the
leadership team that knows about this
what they're doing about it my only
concern is if this thing gets to the
government if the government controls
that button you don't want that no i can
guarantee you don't want that look an
insurance company that we're doing
business with back in the days
aviva i don't know if you remember
back in 2007 2006 they were the number
one insurance company for this product
called the iul they were killing it with
annuities and life i never hear about
aviva anymore yeah because they were
bought out it's a different company now
okay by the way let's stick to aviva
and and uh
one day
everybody gets a call and says hey have
you noticed they're no longer taking as
many policies as they were now this is
people that told me i never did business
with the people but this is like 50
people told me this
i said no why what happened he says it
seems like you know they're no longer
taking underwriting like they did
because they used to i submit 50 clients
like this they accepted all 50 of them
but the last 10 clients i submitted like
this they're no longer taking it what
the hell is going on here
so then from the outside word got out
that they control the knob and the knob
is underwriting underwriting is we will
take a client at this level and we will
not take a client at this level so you
just simply control the knob but in
insurance you make money when you no
longer take premium meaning
it takes seven years for an insurance
policy to be profitable to the insurance
carrier so it's not a short term place a
long long term the number you hear about
is typically seven years okay
so if they have to control the knob and
say oh here's where we're going to go
great i don't mind if aviva has that
knob to control
i worry if the government controls that
knob because aviva controls that knob
guess what there's 50 other insurance
companies i can go to yeah it's going to
be disruptive yeah it's going to be
annoying yeah you know i can't believe
you did this yeah and they did some
stuff that was very shady but they
controlled enough we went to another
insurance company you can go i'm going
to go to this insurance company great
and we interviewed with them we went to
a different insurance company and the
guys that were there at that time they
said yep who left to another company
said that actually happened that's what
we were going through so i i would still
much rather keep this on facebook than
put this on the government because all
it takes is one guy to come in and he
knows like what you talk about with what
obama did with irs
one guy to come in forget about it
forget about it yes forget about it so
think about it right now we're talking
all of a sudden
starts doing the spinning thing and the
video is not going and boom podcast
taken down you can't have this tons of
types of conversation
how many people today this thing's gonna
end up getting say 80 000 views let's
just say give or take 80 000 100 000
just this podcast the short clips say
gets a million views okay total this
thing gets one and a half million views
total with short clips
how many people you think you shifted
their mindset
how many people do you actually think
out of the million and a half you got
them to think and go home and talk to
their husband their wives their kids
their friends their peers their
co-workers how many people have their
mindset been shifted by listening to
this podcast if just one it's shifted
you mean shift no shifted like to the
point where you know i got to tell you i
was listening to podcasts today and the
guys were talking about this and you
know this body will definitely i don't
know yeah but this guy's seven oh no i
know who he is okay and they were
talking with this other guy named jordan
and adam said this and they were saying
this and and i got to tell you i'm
wondering what do you guys think about
this because so then it's like you know
what i'm having a hard time believing
this now and then that conversation goes
to one person two three four five eight
fifty hundred two hundred
that's shifting mindset you're getting
people to start questioning certain
things how many people out at a million
and a half you think are thinking right
now and they're shifting their mindsets
being shifted what do you think what do
you think that number is actually once
you think about this
kai what do you think that number is
1500 okay what do you think that number
is you want like point zero one percent
type of a deal yeah whatever you're
gonna set the over under at i'm taking
the under okay so you're gonna say less
than one percent whatever you're gonna
set the over under is i'm taking the
under okay so can you instead of being
so technical gambler from vegas give us
a number one percent half a percent i i
well if there's any indication of
whether it's going on our country we use
these stats all the time that
you know 45 percent of people are going
to vote democrat 43 are going to percent
uh vote republican
three percent are going to pull a
libertarian and then there's maybe 10
percent maybe you're right that are
changing you're right okay so what
percent so 10
if that great i'm going to go lower
let's just say 50 let's say 10 000
people let's say a thousand to ten
thousand people say single digits let's
say it's a thousand people say it's a
thousand people you know what thousand
people leads to a thousand leads to
ten thousand two hundred thousand very
quickly
it's conversations you had that leads to
dot dot dot dot but imagine if you can't
have those conversations anymore
so that's why i don't want that button
to be controlled by the government i
just don't i you know that's a that's a
great point and to be honest you know i
really don't even care about changing
people's minds i just want them to start
questioning what they there we go being
told i want them to i just shifting
mindsets
yeah just question like you know what
just be inquisitive you know david david
you you're over there you're awake bro
when when you i'm listening when you
first came in right when you you're
you're a little younger you're in a
demographic
i'm sure that you had uh a mentality or
or i'm sure that you had an opinion of
you know capitalist or whatever before
you came here and now six months later
has that opinion changed at all yeah
absolutely i think i had like a vague
understanding of everything um just kind
of what you see online but now obviously
being more immersed than seeing you guys
discuss it day to day it's definitely
changed my opinion on a lot of things
and i see things through a different
sort of um
glass i think just humanizing different
perspectives is the most important thing
like we we are more
and more and more we're driven and maybe
it's because like with what she said on
60 minutes facebook is trying to do this
you know these people are libtards these
people are idiots these people are
maggots these people right and it's
humanizing somebody with a different
perspective is an incredibly important
thing because we we are so much more
alike than we are different all right
even even me and you cami me and you are
so much more alike than we are different
right
but
you know he's talking to kamala harris
gerard just stepped out of his comfort
zone she's staring at me she's looking
right at me but dude she's giving that
little again
i just i hate how manipulated we are in
this moment i hate feeling manipulated
and i hope other people are recognizing
that manipulation they don't have to
agree they can disagree but i want them
to recognize the manipulation that
that's my goal more than anything else
okay let's talk about the next thing
schumer escalates pressure on debt limit
plan
plans vote next
week page five uh
and there's a follow-up to this okay
senate democratic leader chuck schumer
uh ratcheted up pressure on republicans
in their feud over raising the national
debt limit announcing thursday he will
seek a vote as early as next week on
house pass legislation suspending the
legal ceiling senate republicans have
twice blocked the debt ceiling measuring
measures from advance in the 50-50
chamber where 60 votes are needed to
proceed on most legislations if they
want to post
this measure and bring us closer to
financial disaster they can write their
name in the history books as a senator
that would let the country default for
the first time ever but republicans need
to get out of the way so senate
democrats can address this issue quickly
and without endangering the stability of
our economy so schumer says this now
kristin cinema
goes to the bathroom and folks are
following her i had a chance to watch
the video you were telling me about this
and they they literally follow her to
the stall like not to the bathroom door
to the stall and the camera's on she
goes in the stall
comes out she says this is very
inappropriate because you know her and
schumer is not for it but how far you
think this is going to go with the
situation on raising the debt limit
where do you think this is gonna go
gerard
does anybody think this is not getting
passed
i think the only thing is a dollar
amount you think three and a half is
going to get passed i think it's all
negotiation you ask for three and a half
i demand one and a half we settle on 2.7
and the american pays for it all i did i
mean how many times have we seen this
game we've this this is this is how we
govern now you know the the remarkable
failure of our current government is to
pass
horrible horrible legislature and then
use years of horrible legislature to
take away what we did the way that we
legislate now for people that don't know
how pork works inside of bills
they say it we need to pass it so we
know what's in it we need to pass it so
we know what's in it so we get this this
insane
50 000 page bill that's written by
lobbyists it's not written by our actual
elected officials anymore lobbyists all
right professional bribers put parts of
the bill in then they pass the bill
based on nothing more than party
affiliation and then over the course of
the next five six seven eight nine ten
years the more egregious aspects of the
bill will be whittled away within pork
inside of other bills so in the in the
budget there will be an addendum on page
3290 you know addendum 13 part b uh
section 2 that says okay the uh gas mile
tax that we put in under the biden
infrastructure act in 2001 was a bad
idea we're getting rid of that so we'll
have that bill for seven years it's a
constant kick that can all right
what
again guys
why are we paying
why are we paying taxes if all we have
to do
to to fund everything if it costs
nothing why are they taking your money
why are they taking your money why are
they taking your money why don't you
guys just print more money
you know if this is what we're doing now
if we're all kenzians now why are you
taking people's money
spending more of it than you have and
then
giving them a bill for the future as
well
and we're just sitting here taking it we
just sit here and go yeah no problem we
can't default how dare we default if
these guys can't run the country or five
trillion dollars how are they going to
run the system is set up that way right
and then you got mansion comes out and
says one and a half trillion is my limit
that i'm going to go on the biden
economic agenda amid battle with
progressive this is a cnn story moderate
democratic he says has made it clear one
and a half trillion was a price tag that
he was willing to settle uh on his party
uh a plan to expand the safety net
putting him two trillion dollars away
from the lowest number of progressive
democrats have said they would expect
i've never been a liberal in any way
shape or form mentions that i'm willing
to come from zero to one and a half
trillion manchin has noted that congress
has spent 5.4 trillion dollars since
last march in response to the pandemic
and yes asked he asked at some point all
of us regardless of party must ask the
simple question how much is enough you
gotta love this guy yeah you gotta love
this guy
yeah the fact that they have like what
the 2500 page report
i'll be damned if anyone shows me
something like that and you can't tell
me 50 pages of it that's my problem
pat you run an insurance company if you
had 2 000 freaking pages of like
policies and this and that the other you
would definitely be able to just discuss
this and be able to
expand
if it's a decision to spend
if it's the decision because what's
three and a half trillion dollars what
part of the gdp is three and a half
trillion dollars what percentage of the
gdp is that like what's our what's
what what percentage what's our gdp 20
20 trillion that's how i'm doing it 20
trillion three and a half trillion on 20
trillion 17
so so so if the company is doing
uh a hundred million dollars easy math
so yeah this thing's gonna cost us 17
million dollars yeah no no you don't you
don't just say let's go and do it it's
going to be a ton of research commentary
going back and forth why do we need to
spend 17 why can't we take of course
we're gonna have a lot of color behind
it but these guys are sitting there
saying listen let's just go get that 17
million and find out what we're gonna do
with this money tell me one bank that's
gonna say yes so essentially in a
situation like this we're the bank and
the bankers are saying don't worry about
it go ahead and do it that's the part
that i'm uncomfortable with
where it's like you know and i know we
voted our
leaders for them to go hash this out and
make the decision for themselves
but still
there's no accountability to what
happens with that money so you take on
that money you take on that debt you run
a company and you default or or you
don't use that money wisely what happens
to you and your company you know you're
out of business there's serious
serious consequences what happens to
these guys it's not their money they get
re-elected
they get re-elected they get re-elected
because the amount of people that they
give the money to yeah there's a carrot
where's the stick
yeah anyways by the way we uh we are
getting to the end of it uh i do want to
give a shout out to a couple people we
haven't even covered everybody that's
given these super chats one of the ones
i'll give is julie swenson gave 49
dollars and i saw the interview with the
whistleblower i now have i i now
question myself do i get off the
platform or stay for business what does
that say about me my morals my values
anyone else feel this way pretty
interesting for example exactly
who come from the uh the vault peters
once i think so okay i think so
yeah
i think so that's a great question for
her to ask but you know uh we may do
yanomi park tomorrow we're still talking
about it we may do something on podcast
tomorrow because i'm not here thursday
i'm out of town this week so we're not
gonna podcast we gotta get her early
because i think she flies out wednesday
what time is it okay we'll figure it out
if we can if we can we'll do podcast
tomorrow so folks stay tuned we're
definitely not doing it on thursday
because i'm out of town but we may do it
tomorrow with that being said if you've
not seen the interview with sean spiegel
kai
put that link both in the chat box as
well as
in the commentary for folks to see
and if you like what we're doing gang
here's how you can help us if you want
to see this thing continue give us the
thumbs up share this with your peers and
subscribe to the channel the bigger this
get the more messages being heard the
more time we'll put into this podcast as
well that's the way you'll show us it if
you like the content that we're putting
let's maybe make a challenge well let's
give people a homework assignment let's
watch that episode sean spiegel that's
the homework assignment
and then you know we're odds people here
right
we're we're currently this is episode 93
we're currently sitting at 87 000
subscribers
by episode 100
we got to hit a hundred thousand
is that realistic i think that's very
real can we make that happen i think can
you tell your friends realistic if you
like gerard tell your friends about
gerard who doesn't like phil if you hate
me all good i love you too man sorry man
so but tell your friends get part of
this you got to fill the description of
that video i just want to look them up
his name is not searchable so his
descript the description for that video
needs to be put up there
i don't know if you know what i'm saying
or not yeah there's nothing on there
that you can't find that interview but
we'll handle that and uh if you haven't
put the link below yet i just posted it
on the chat there you go and put in the
comment section i know we've got one
minute left yeah but you know as a not a
car guy i got to bring up this car
situation what the hell was that how did
we go yeah oh we can't go two hours no
but give us a little 60 second gone in
60 seconds like never was that you drove
it how was it yesterday when you drove
it honestly
a dream
can you put up the picture by the way
unreal what have you driven so the
audience knows what else you've driven
i've driven la ferrari i've drove a
shiron bugatti i've driven a pista i've
driven mclarens
you're a car guy absolutely
this is your car guy this car i'm a
subway guy but
i got to tell you this car right here
look how sexy
man congrats pat
congrats i'm gonna blow your mind a
little bit what it does nothing for me i
know it doesn't i know i know but i love
that you get in there and you're like oh
oh
oh no that's how you going to get in a
lift when adam gets inside oh my gosh a
lift a lift amazing i see how excited
now that that would be
that would be some big content we get
you a uber account and you start ubering
around classic well i'll tell you i'll
give you a quick little story i i was in
a lift last night at this oslo freedom
forum i knew this girl we were going to
go out to this like after party thing we
get in the lift she's from berkeley
super smart girl
you know very attractive
she gets in the land i'm an experienced
uber lyft guy we get in
she's got her mask on
i don't have my mask on because i just
you know
i'm good
she's like what are you doing i go what
are you doing and we're having this
conversation i'm masculist she's massed
up she's
i was like take your [ __ ] mask off
that was it that was the story but in
the back of a lift it went down
anyways folks tomorrow we may do podcast
stay tuned we'll announce that if not
we're going to do it next week everybody
have a great weekend bye bye bye bye